you've been accused of breaking the law
in checkers and the Downing Street did
you no but you'll look
um it's there if it's proved that you
did are you finished as a politician
the answer is that
um
as I said before there was absolutely no
uh
rule breaking and you know
what proof do you have of that
well look you know those who want to
make allegations should make allegations
and so far nobody has and you're my
honest view I think this whole thing is
completely nonsensical and look I got to
check in for a flight now this whole
thing is a load of absolute nonsense
um
I think it was absurd that
it was decided to pass entries in my
diary to the uh
police what do these entries say what do
these entries say they merely record
events in my uh in my day